foreign
[Music]
ER welcome to sogcast number 22. today
we have an interesting guest and uh we
were our interviews are focusing on SOG
related Adventures from the Vietnam War
where we had the eight-year secret War
under the Aegis of the military
assistance command of Vietnam and uh
also we always thank Jocko willing
productions for making these recordings
possible to record the history from our
unique Niche during the Vietnam war and
I'm reading here
um
he jumped up shooting into the tree line
running forward and hoping someone was
following
in a ragged line they were the well and
the walking wounded
their shot up comrades providing
covering fire
fleeting thoughts struck him
as he ran forward
how easy it was to get through
the elephant grass since most of it had
been neatly mowed by Bullet Skies
how little noise there was except the
blood rushing in his ears
how the specks of fire in front of him
looked almost beautiful even though he
knew them to be muzzle flashes
how his legs seemed to carry him in
possible distances with each stride
and yet far away
the tree line continued to be
how could the mountain yards run faster
than he
yet here they were surrounding him
firing as they ran
their faces contorted with effort
in front of him went to grinning back at
him when he shouted at them to get out
of his way
one stumbled
coughed a great gout of bright red blood
the other took his place
and what was this
a tree
it took a moment to realize that he was
out of the open
all around him were scenes of carnage
pieces of corpses draped and abandoned
half in and half out of collapsed
bunkers
steam rising from torsos ripped apart by
the blast
and the people were still shooting at
him
the artillery hadn't killed them all not
nearly
there a foxhole he had run completely by
a rifle muzzle was protruding from it
firing at his people
he pulled an M26 grenade from its keeper
yanked the pin and let the spoon fly
training more training now took over
let it cook off count one thousand two
one thousand pop it down the hole take
cover
in two seconds not enough time for a man
in the hole to find it and throw it out
it goes off blowing the camouflage cover
off the hole and fill in the air with
black smoke of high explosive
nobody could live through that
but better make sure jump up point the
M16 down at the hole look into the
muzzle of an AK-47 being held by a very
much alive if somewhat explosive
adeled NBA Soldier Jesus
finger locks down on the trigger 20
rounds of 5.56 into him
rendering a human into a pile of bloody
rags
this is from a book that we call fiction
days of Fire
written by John F Mullins one of 14
books he's written
12 of which have been published two of
which are at the print shop getting
ready to come out and today I want to
welcome John Mullins to the show and
even though it's fiction
John this has a feel of you having been
there a little bit so take us back to
start off with this scene it's just
surreal you captured that combat your
yards and uh take us to that day where
you were please it was one of those days
where you you want to fight because I'd
been out there for days and days and
days and got nothing other than cut some
sniper rounds
and when one of my yards said tell me oh
Trung Lee pointed up to this hill and
said Bo buku VC I said let's go get them
sort of a dumbass move I will will admit
but uh once we did start up that hill it
was a matter of you got to keep going or
you might get killed let's get well if
you're going if you stay where you are
you're definitely going to get killed
you go back down the hill you're going
to get killed so the choice was fairly
easy all right so at that time
um
uh you had a total of three tours of
Duty in Vietnam with special forces at
different assignments and he had that
one extension for your last tour Duty so
this was your second tour duty but the
action you've captured in your book here
I just thought it was compelling to at
least get us started and uh talk a
little bit about during your second time
you were working at an a camp and you're
on patrol and I just love the way you
captured that moment in time and uh so a
little bit about where the a camp was at
that point you were first lieutenant
first lieutenant right have you been
promoted by then and uh just fill us in
a little bit about that scenery and then
we'll take it from there because that's
you captured that combat
the camp itself was called Venton uh and
and that was because it was in the
Benton Valley up in the central
Highlands Vietnam
it was a horrible place for Camp to be
because you were down in the bottom of
the valley mountains all around you they
could shoot down into your Camp any time
they wanted to the entire Camp was built
underground concreted over the only
thing that remained above ground was the
latrine uh so it was always fun to be
sitting on there doing your business and
here and know that that's a mortar going
off so how far away was the nearest uh
trench line you could dive into the
within within feet
[Laughter]
so you had that experience a couple
times too I assume yes I did oh
there's nothing like being on the on the
crapper and then here that round get
dropped into a mortitube
that's a yeah definitely recognizing the
sound
oh well okay
um if you don't mind I'd like to
um uh flash forward to when you return
to Vietnam for the third time and uh
I think that was 1969
and you come back 68 and then
um you return to Vietnam uh did they
required you to go through the
in-country training at that point or did
you just yeah headquarters yeah you did
the in-country training yeah I still had
to go through the uh what they call it
the [__] course at that time right uh
yeah I still had to do it pissed me off
as you can imagine yeah he's in my third
tour previously yeah but uh you do what
you do bureaucracy is as we all know
well and they weren't necessarily
nonchalant towards the duty I mean you
earned how many silver stars and how
many purple hearts during the first two
tours of Duty the first tour tours are
Duty I got one Silver Star One Purple
Heart uh second Tour of Duty I got
another Silver Star and avoided getting
into purple heart so I was tired of that
yeah we'll come back to the other Purple
Heart a little bit later but we gotta
get into the sog stuff first because
this is what our viewers tune Us in for
so you go through the in-country
training and then from there
um how do you hear how do you hear about
song or had you heard about it and what
was the process that went through your
mind that eventually lend you going to
Longton for a very unique assignment
there which again it's another first
we've been talking about
SOG was never one of those things that
you didn't hear about in Special Forces
I mean everybody pretty much knew what
was going on uh and I would I just
hadn't had the opportunity I always more
thought I wanted to go to song so when I
was on the way back over and Mark
ponzillo uh with major Mark bunzel old
friend told me that he was going to SOG
and I should come with him I said okay
I'm ready to go uh where we went a long
time
uh so at the end country train like in
our case again we were there in 68 this
is May for us and when we went through
the in country at the end of it I forget
some little guy comes out hey we're
looking for volunteers and Johnny
McIntyre goes for what and he says well
can't say either you're in or you're out
of course we signed of course 1968 the
movie The Green Berets with the Duke had
been out for a while and uh in fact
that's the first time we saw it was
there at the training group I mean the
headquarters for Special Forces Group so
um your buddy takes you there and you go
down if you explain a little bit about
long time because by that point Longton
had been a SOG base but they hadn't
formally started the 1-0 school yet that
came a little bit later but it was there
nonetheless because I don't know
anything about it you were there what
was going on a long time at that time
yeah it was uh other than my project it
was mostly the the 1-0 uh getting
everybody one ready for the 1-0
um but my project was called Borden uh
so it got a nickname of course we were
doing the milk run
but this was a notional project it was
specifically designed to
spread hate and discontent in the rural
areas of the North Vietnamese and that
all across the fence either in Cambodia
or layoffs Cambodia layoffs and before
the the bombing health of 68 right
November 68 Johnson November 68 yeah
when we couldn't fly there anymore we'd
been going into North Vietnam
no kidding
so how um again excuse my complete
ignorance because this is the first time
I've heard of that and that's why I like
having you here amongst the other firsts
but um so how will that program work how
would you recruit people first because
I'm assuming you're recruiting uh former
via Kong NVA Cadre or soldiers they come
in and then through some kind of a
vetting process you all determine here's
a candidate with somebody we could work
with if we talk to him about our program
our values maybe we can get them to work
for us and then if they agreed you
trained them up and then once you're
done training what did they do
yeah it was uh we we got them out of POW
camps okay they uh we would go around
and do interviews
and
the of course this was Vietnamese that
was also involved in the project and he
would he would Scout him out and tell
who were possibilities who weren't uh
once had picked them we'd take them up
to take them up to Longton and put them
in the compound there and start their
training and start their indoctrination
one of the best ways we had to show them
that they had been steadily lied to
because they had been told that the
Americans had wrecked the entire country
with everything people were starving and
so forth and so on would take them down
to Saigon
was that right yeah a little suppositor
psyops yeah let them let them take them
obviously we we weren't we kept a close
eye on them but but they saw all the
piccolos crowding the streets and the
street vendors and everybody looked
happy and they realized it was like a
light bulb going off to them we've been
lied to all this time so they were much
more amenable so you could say it was
dramatically different than living in
Hanoi or in the pits of a Vietcong
Village vastly lying to people vastly
yeah uh I never thought about that
that's a great tool psyops as best yeah
it worked yeah okay so then uh what
would be the general training cycle
would it depend on the individuals that
said how pretty much done an assessment
between you and your counterparts yeah
it's pretty much constant uh constant
check and
I will say this for the Vietnamese
officers we had they were very smart and
they I could tell a liar and a heartbeat
where we couldn't a guy could probably
lie to you and you're nod there and
saying yep yep
so the ones that we didn't want were
weaned out and they went back to the POW
camps the ones that we did want that
showed some potential then we started
training them on what they would do once
they were reinserted into North into
denied areas sure because I know
we did the same thing with our team when
it got wiped out we had to recruit
people and we just turned it over to our
zero one the Vietnamese team leader and
our interpreter and they had a couple of
people on the team they would vet
anybody came on the team and then we run
through our security check whatever that
was and we hired four new people right
away yeah I mean right away meaning
within a few weeks
and uh but the trust our counterparts to
do the job too or indeed and like you
said an instinctual thing I I knew that
they were better than that so you guys
met him and we never had a problem at
least on our team and eventually you
sounded you had a lot of success there
too yeah we did uh we never had uh we we
only had one that I would say might have
been a double uh but but we put him into
an air put him inserted him into an area
where he could do the most harm by
telling all the lives we'd fed him
so then
um
what would be the next step once trained
then uh how would you pick a Target area
and then in search would be a helicopter
would they walk in or what would the
next step be no it was too far to walk
right uh so it was either by helicopter
or We parachuted the man oh no kidding
yeah and would it be like static line or
static static line static line shop yeah
okay and then uh so this is 68 68 and
69. yeah yeah and that program was
successful at some point you said you
had very successful yeah we we got Intel
back uh mostly signal intelligence uh
that there was at least a division of
North Vietnamese wandering around
somewhere up around the Ho Chi Minh
trail trying to find all these
infiltrators who were pre passing
information back to us they weren't but
that's okay sure and when you're when
your people went in when they did go in
if did they were they looking to make
contact so they didn't talk to people
what would they be when they were on the
ground and how old would they be they
were supposed to just uh provide Intel
with a little radio so we provide Intel
right we very seldom got in the Intel
they were tumbled within days of of
insertion no kidding yeah wow they had a
pretty good
net over across the border they use you
didn't just wander around there no
and so were you able to get any back no
no kidding not a one all right and so
um this program goes on for a while that
at some point
you you learn about or hear about a
project that was probably one of the
most successful during the Vietnam war
although there was a degree of
controversy attached to the Phoenix
project
drew that that is saying it nicely yes
but so again because uh I heard about
tangentially only after my second tour
Duty or if I knew about on my first tour
it was just like an enigma for us so not
only did I not hear about your program
from long time but we didn't know about
the Phoenix project but you did and
again this is your third tour of Duty so
you're really Savvy in country you know
more people and uh so what's your
introduction to the Phoenix project I
I'd always known about The Phoenix
Program back uh that had had various
names it had been going on for years but
uh so the Vietnamese decided to name it
Fung law uh fungwa is Phoenix right in
English
and that was the that was the dragon or
the burger rather that emulated itself
every year and then came back stronger
and that was the idea of it so they our
purpose was to officially was to
neutralize the Vietcong infrastructure
in country in country yeah we never
operated out of country not in Phoenix
no and the one of the key points it's
here that is often overlooked that by
the time you're talking about here which
would be 6869 and and the Phoenix
problem program ran for 67 to 72 I
believe yeah
um
but what aspect was there oh the North
Vietnamese government or Army would
always have Cadre or staff communist
agent who would be present with the Viet
Cong working different districts and how
could you just break that down a little
bit further too yeah it was it wasn't
just the the North Vietnamese didn't
trust anybody certainly from the south
right uh so yeah they would put people
with the village Chiefs these Province
Chiefs to make sure that they towed the
party line but these were hardcore
Vietcong in the first place so it was it
was sort of a conflict between the two
because oh yeah the guys were we'd get
one of the one of the higher ups and
we'd talk to them about that and they
would show their anger at being
not trusted by their North Vietnamese
allies
uh so yeah it definitely was some uh was
some real problems but that's also an
accurate reflection on the North
Vietnamese Communists who wanted to
control everything South and on one hand
things are being portrayed to the media
about oh the Vietcong with the local
farmers that farm by day plowed by day
but at night they go out and they're
good soldiers now there were some that
left over from the French into China war
and some of those vietnames were good
but yes they were but after the French
left the columnist dominated North
Vietnam and they wanted to dominate the
whole country south exactly and when
their people came South to work with the
little villages
and the people therein there was that
hostility we don't hear about much no
and you saw it firsthand oh yeah yeah
very definitely when when they first
started up uh most of the people who
were put in down into into the South
were guys who had been Vietcong or
Vietnam I should say right yeah during
the French end or China war
um and knew the country and knew the
people there so they were they were put
into those areas deliberately because of
that because of their knowledge but the
lack of trust came later on and the
North Vietnamese started sending their
Cadre in there and yeah I created some
hate and discontent indeed and were you
able to play a play upon that a little
bit when we played upon it a lot uh we'd
uh we would get these guys and before I
go into that though the one of the
things I want to clarify sure there's
been so much nonsense about The Phoenix
Program about how it was an
assassination program uh we were going
in there and killing people willy-nilly
uh it was anything but that
uh one thing you can't get information
off a dead man that's a little difficult
even today very difficult unless you've
got a pocket letter that you can use
maybe some documents but uh but that's
that's betting on the come indeed so my
biggest problem was keeping him alive uh
because my crew were their families had
been policed up during tet 68 and buried
in the sand dunes outside the way
so they had a grudge and they wanted to
kill them all sure understandable and
that's why that brings us back to a
basic question I didn't ask you first
where did you start with the When you
entered the Phoenix project your way
which is i-core which is the northern
part of South Vietnam and then later you
also picked up some responsibilities in
Quang tree province which was further to
the Northeast away further further north
yeah North yes sir and um so what would
be the um set up for you as a phoenix
officer there would be some command and
Control Officers how many people there
and then how many counterparts and then
the good stuff where Phoenix would
identify through their rapport with
local citizens to say there's a Viacom
he's a Vietcong then you all would work
to
bring him in capture them keep them
alive talk to them interrogate them to
get Intel and then to eventually to help
change their thinking or to put them in
incarcerate them yes exactly if you get
a little bit of that structure because
again this is
I'm so excited about interviewing you
today was because this is my first
insight for real we had guys that were
with us said yeah I was in the Phoenix
project well what was it well uh
you know Mumble mouth yeah but now 15
years later we can talk about a little
bit further and to get it on the record
with the straight skivvy from somebody
who was there so if you don't mind it's
a little bit more of the structure and
then maybe one or two your successes
will you go out and get Joe bip the rag
man who knows Viet Cong he comes in you
do some of your psyops and say hey by
the way you know we're good people here
it's different than the way the
Communists are and you flip them and
they work for you a little bit and take
it from there please yeah the the
structure first off we got a lot of our
Intel off of say again all right and we
were tied into virtually everybody who
couldn't provide us then and you were
working with Asa at the time I assume
working with Asa working with uh with
some uh what were called
Province Intelligence Officers that were
fresh out of uh Fort Holabird who uh who
were a little bit out of their uh a
little bit elderly a little bit out of
there and just for the record the ASA
was the Army Security Agency as the
Forerunner of the NSA today's NSA yeah
uh which has generated a few headlines
in recent years through its notoriety
but the ASA really was on our side they
did gain valuable Intel both off of
signal and they had their people that
Americans that were trained in a
language monitor their frequencies and
from that they could give you Intel yes
and so take it for nearer how you would
get and we'd get Intel from The Province
uh the Providence Chiefs uh in these
places because they had their own Intel
net out too the Vietnamese Providence
Chiefs
that that were certainly may maintaining
knowledge of who who the VC were and
where they were and what what the
capabilities were so we'd get that until
we put it all together and anything else
that we could get and then we would
specifically Target somebody or a bunch
of somebody's and just for another a
course of background here just for
listeners who may not be familiar uh
early at the end of January early
February 1968
it was the historic Tet Offensive Ted is
the annual New Year event in Vietnam in
1968 the Congress and the Americans
agree that there would be a truce during
the tent of course the calmness being
the lying dogs that they are
um lied and they launched their biggest
offensive during the war at that point
and they had Viacom NVA had infiltrated
into the country attacked major bases
embassies and a way we had to weigh
Massacre where
the NVA came into the historic Citadel
area of way
and they killed
or took anybody was educated priests
people who were of authority Mayors
people who were the infrastructure of a
successful thriving Community took him
out and killed him and this is of course
again the media did not give this much
ink as it should have been and this was
a massacre way Massacre and I forget
what was the the projected body count on
that oh I don't remember but it was
astronomical is it several thousand at
least oh yeah definitely and uh they
were digging bodies out of uh out of the
sand dunes for months yes sir and so
with that set that was also something
that you could use when you're talking
to the survivors
in The Villages you could use that and
then they would help pinpoint to be a
con the NVA Cadre that were in your
areas of operation there yeah the
hardest part was to convince somebody
say in a village that we could protect
them because they had been uh as you saw
aptly said terrorized so once we
convinced them then we got good Intel
and we could move up the chain we get a
roadrunner somebody who is carrying
messages one way or the other we get him
we find out who the messages are coming
from uh we take that one out he tells us
then who the messages were generated
from and it goes on and on and on until
we get up to the people who are at the
highest level District chiefs were uh
and of course they had a province Chief
but the district chiefs were our primary
target
and uh with with that you would remove
them and then incarcerate them and or
try to flip them first but that would
always be the flip or just depend on the
degree of notoriety we'd try to get
immediate Intel off of them
but but we were pretty restricted from
that we had a tournament within a few
days right so the intel was the
important part to us give us Intel who
is who else is in this chain where are
they how well are they guarded and then
formulate another operation off of that
they would pull them away from us pretty
quickly the Vietnamese government had
pull them away from us pretty quickly
and put them put them down in Hong Kong
is that right yeah and then um
you also your area of operation was
expanded to include Quang tree yeah and
then how did that go and then again was
it like a gradual thing one Village at a
time as you spread out your Facebook
your Intel Network basically one Village
at a time yeah and I just it was there
one or two major successes where you get
the The Village Chieftain or somebody
who's like a key player in the village
who you know is Hardcore via Kong but
you bring him in you capture and you
talk to them you interrogate them
there's different methods but you
interrogate him in a regular
interrogation like mono mono and then
you begin to see maybe we can change
this guy so was there a couple of
success stories where there are some
people you brought in like that there
were and a large part of that was
because of the aforementioned tet 68
when basically the Vietcong was
decimated
they were shot to Pieces they were they
were pissed the survivors because the
North Vietnamese hadn't given them the
support that they had been promised so
they not a little fact we never hear
about oh yeah yeah they they weren't
happy about that and uh and it gets to
the stage where you'd pick somebody up
oh God I'm glad to see you guys
having so many words sure yeah but again
that was a critical part of the
operation you flip them yes they didn't
work for you and as there as you went up
that chain and command there's a couple
of cases where uh that stick out in your
mind you said hey we've got news and
confusion here
and yeah he's working with us and we're
able to get
other high-ranking Viacom and if you
know you couldn't flip them but you get
them out of the village yes out of the
province into a jail
and then you would be able to pacify the
village and the village could Thrive get
back to living without the calmness
domination which was the one of the
goals of the Phoenix project indeed I
think one of my favorites is the
time when a North Vietnamese Battalion
came down the Ho Chi Minh trail uh came
in through the ashaw valley and were
lost for two weeks lost lost there were
no more Trail Watchers there were no
more support supplies where there was
nobody else there to support them
because we'd polished them all up no
so we factored in we got an Intel how
did that work I mean that that's amazing
okay let me pull my mind back together
here a little bit so talk to me a little
bit more about that that sounds like an
amazing success story it was it
certainly it was my best one there's no
question about it I really liked it even
better when I was able to call up the
101st that was operating in the area
sure and tell them where they were and
they went in and just annihilated that
Battalion wow so how that started so you
had worked on some local people they're
helping you and they say hey by the way
you should talk to this guy who may know
about this essentially and of course we
still had the Intel coming in from ASA
all NSA yeah and the Vietnamese did you
ever get anything good for the CIA that
was really usable no of course not okay
just want to get that for the record no
certainly not they always wanted to get
stuff from us but yeah no they uh they
were far too high level to speak to a
mirror Captain indeed indeed
so okay fix it so you get somebody who
takes you to somebody then what happened
um the uh I'm sorry you're talking about
the 101st and it came down and you were
able to get an Intel Network that lets
you know they're coming and then your
Trail watches disappeared and then you
get the 101st who hit it with their
gunships and uh did they use ground
troops also over the yeah
yeah so yeah just tell me a little bit
more if you can yeah I don't know that
much about about the operation itself I
just knew that it happened you just got
it started yeah yeah you're the action
point here's the Intel here's where they
are go kill those commies and they did
and they did
the uh the other one was up in Quan Cree
Province where we got the Providence
Chief uh and that was the Big Kahuna for
the whole thing wow he's the one who ran
everything and he was another one who
was totally disgruntled with the way he
had been treated you were able to flip
him oh he was he was he was a gold mine
well that's amazing so then was there a
success story from him because through
him cooperating then you go out and get
more to Viet Cong and then you knew who
the NBA cat you were also they're coming
into the village yeah exactly and in
most cases they were so paranoid that
they were surrounded by platoons of
guards so there was no capturing there
was that right yeah I was direct assault
oh okay so how so then you would work
that would you would coordinate that
with any of the a camps or with the
101st or other units then or just no you
wouldn't know identify them and then
move on no it was my Pro who did it was
that right yeah so
um just again for our listeners Prue is
the action arm of the Phoenix project
yes and what exactly does that mean and
how does that shape out like once you
all develop the Intel through your
interrogations
then they go out and uh prove the
provincial reconnaissance units
basically it is uh it is it's it's not a
military operation it's actually a
police operation uh and they work very
very closely with the director General
National Police
uh but these guys were uh they were
always from the area there's no
Outsiders we wanted to make sure of that
sure and we the
they were very very well trained through
a succession of crew advisors who had
come before me and I trusted them with
my life I did it many times
I was the only American out there so I
pretty much had to trust them well yeah
and also I I think this is a reflection
of your character I think that
um
The Phoenix Program directors
try to discourage young captains or
first lieutenants from actually going to
the field and by this time this is your
third tour of Duty you'd seen it you had
your Silver Star purple heart and you
went out with him which was a unique
aspect of that so your modesty hats on
if you just take that off for a minute
what it was like how would you approach
would you be with two or three of the
guys just go into a village at night or
how would you work that it would depend
on the target
sometimes we could go by stealth and get
into a village get the person we wanted
snatch them and come back out other
times it was full-scale assault
anywhere from Platoon up to a company
that large yeah whoa so and then who
that would be South Vietnamese soldiers
working with you all then no that was
strictly the proof I had 120 man
improved Detachment
and they were extreme really good
soldiers and who trained them up to be
so the other crew advisors who had come
before me and those are all SF all SF
wow
I never I never realized well again
there's no book you can trust that I've
read today no and
um I didn't realize you had that kind of
training you know that kind of manpower
wow okay so
um
as it you're in that program for how
long is there any other little sidebars
or issues did you get wounded on any of
those operations or get a little
shrapnel for good luck doing some of
those things where you're just hanging
out with the local pru Lads no I uh I
got wounded three more times
while I was out with them but we had I
had a problem uh because we were it
wasn't just that they didn't want us out
there with them we were told absolutely
it's a career Buster if we find that you
have been out on an operation with Peru
now that wasn't going working for me
right uh so I went out you know if I'm
10 years in the Army okay by then and uh
you know I like it but it ain't my life
so I went out with the pro
yeah but it was also a critical element
to you having success in the field and
it's also
an incredible uh
builder of character and like Esprit de
corps between you and the men you're
working with instead of just saying hey
this platoon go on out and take these
guys out you're like they're with them
exactly and they can see you're serious
and then we'll do so that's one side of
it and then what about the hearts and
Minds side did you have uh SF Medics
come in do the village type uh working
with or how without any other uh
we pretty much kept ourselves uh on it
uh everybody was scared shitless of the
probe because of all the rumors that had
gone around and I liked it that way
because we didn't get uh we we didn't
get hassles from the from the Vietnamese
certainly right and we didn't get had
too much hassles from all the American
civilians that were running around
thinking that they knew exactly how to
win the war
and and at some point the command
shifted to chords and and when the
Phoenix project was under chords at
first if you could explain what chords
was and then did they have an impact on
the Phoenix brother big impact
um basically uh it was one day in
January of 70. that I got a Twix a
telephonic uh
topshivakama yeah yeah uh that said pack
your bags you're leaving
really oh yeah uh and everybody every
other advisor Pro advisors in the
country got the same twigs they shut us
shut us out this was shortly after say
senator J William Fulbright got up in
the floor of the Senate and denounced
The Phoenix Program as being an
assassination program and so forth and
the military didn't want uh didn't want
their names uh attached to it so
basically we were thrown out of Vietnam
until we can never go back
wow so but the program continues so who
we do you continue they went uh some
civilians uh uh and I don't know it but
what I've heard is the the efficiency of
it went completely in the toilet and at
that point was John Paul Van still
around to work with the courts program
he was down south yeah he was down south
but yeah everybody knew John Paul Vance
and so without a negative uh side of
that was that part I don't know if you
know or not but that's one of the names
that rings out because of course his
years there he did a lot of good but
changing gutting The Phoenix Program
that doesn't sound like a good idea no
it's terrible idea yeah I thought it was
down and done for political reasons and
political reasons seldom
uh are good reasons for anything and
then
um just for the record I think that we
talked about
um the Phoenix project there were
probably over 81
000 Vietcong and maybe a few NBA for
good luck who were quote neutralized and
that would mean people who came over to
our side or were incarcerated or who did
die in some combat between pru units and
your agents yes and unlike the portrayal
where
um
there was
um people who would go out and
uh say a villager had a grudge with
another villager and say well I'm with
the pru they would go out and just I'll
just go kill somebody today yeah and
with you working you knew who your
people were you knew what the targets
were so I assume but I guess the direct
question would be was there abuses and
if they were did you hear about it and
what would be done there were attempted
abuses uh at least when I was there sure
and those came from the Vietnamese right
uh somebody wanted uh wanted somebody
had been hurt in a business transaction
uh somebody had somebody's wife had gone
run off with somebody else
so they you know the dramas is always
there it doesn't matter if you're in the
middle of war or not right so they would
attempt to insert information on their
enemy into the program
and you had some of these young
lieutenants who would take it you know
yeah that probably what happened we
ought to tell them tell the Phoenix guys
and they can get this guy
we always double checked everything that
we got from anybody yeah to make damn
sure that we were getting the wrong
getting the right people because that
would have destroyed the program uh
right from the beginning nobody would
have trusted this anymore nobody would
have given this Intel uh it would have
been totally ineffective and I think in
some cases that's what they wanted well
of course and I it's very tempting to
think that somebody would leak something
like that to a senator who at that time
was a very powerful force in the U.S
Senate indeed so with mouse of a
forethought which is this is one way to
hurt a program that's kicking our ass in
Vietnam sure even though nobody knew
about it you guys did a great job
um so
um was there any uh side notes to that
that the follow-ups for the Phoenix
project as we wrap up this part of the
conversation on any other thought I mean
had they not J William fawbright had not
put the kabas to this and heard it and
then of course the subsequent publicity
a lot erroneous in nature most erroneous
um would their what was your project how
successful could that have been would
that have been a Major Impact because
this is 1970 and as you said which again
facts that weren't reported well was the
Viet Cong ranks were decimated that were
doing the Ted offensive and
by 69 and 70 they were still hurt and
you guys with the Phoenix project or
whoever via Kong or left or the new ones
coming in you knew them neutralized them
one way or the other yeah a couple may
have died a long way that's good the
best comedy my favorite kind of economy
is a dead comedy I don't know about you
John button I'm biased that way and then
um
I'm just trying to think if there was
another aspect to that well there is an
aspect to it and that is uh the
aforementioned
Viet Cong who was pretty much policed up
were being replaced by North Vietnamese
and we're going after them uh and
frankly they weren't all that
de rigor or North Vietnamese uh oh is
that right oh yeah yeah we'd get them uh
we'd uh and they were scared shut of the
crew anyway sure they figured that the
moment that they got in the crew they
were dead man
and when they found out no that wasn't
going to happen they realized they'd
been lied to too so here again is a
major fundamental difference that was
never reported not written about to the
best of my knowledge if it was I still
haven't read the book I'm not going to
read until you tell me I should read it
um and uh
that actual fact was
the trend in Vietnam War at that time we
had hurt them and there was a you know
we were we were winning the war and
you're hurting them at the
infrastructure level and with the North
Vietnamese putting their people in there
those are strangers coming into a
village that you all have won the hearts
and Minds helped to get them back on
their feet as a thriving Village without
the Communist thugs around to intimate
intimidate them and the only way people
go along with the Communists is the
comments are there with their guns yeah
exactly and then the Village People is
where we got a lot of our Intel the
straightforward Intel at that point
because that exactly that had happened
somebody some guy had come in there and
started bullying everybody and eyeing
the women and yeah they uh so somebody
would find a reason to talk to somebody
else who they knew were talking to
somebody else and we'd get the Intel and
we'd uh we'd go in and take them yeah I
mean even with the
um with the way Massacre I mean yes a
lot of people were killed but a lot of
women and boys were terribly brutalized
first oh dude and rape pillage plundered
and
um then just killed murdered like the
typical way in the tradition of Joseph
Stalin Mayo test tongue and the boys yep
yes sir and again oh I don't know why
our me just didn't get around to
reporting that side of it very much
because the media by then had turned
completely against uh you know you had
Walter Cronkite Uncle Walt yeah going
through and saying the war is lost uh
and people started believing that you
had a very strong anti-war movement from
all the draft Dodgers mostly uh here in
the United States and uh we had
politicians Running Scared and then also
we should point out that the Communists
did have some people
that were motivating people into the
anti-war movement oh god there was
support for it and again I don't know if
much has been written about that uh I
know Mark Levin talks about it sometimes
these days but again there are sort of
books about that but getting back to
what we're dealing with in Vietnam the
tide was positive Oh indeed you out
perfect example is when I took over
Quang tree province I had to move
between whey and uh and up in Quang tree
uh so is that Highway one yeah Highway
One
so I'd hop in my dream alone
um carry a gun of course but I'd drive
up there and drive back never an issue
that's the street without Joy right
from the book speak without Joy yeah was
documented how the vietmen decimated the
French on the street without joy and
just for a little personal sidebar here
from fob 1 to way it was 10 miles and we
drove up there several times and we had
heard about the Marines getting ambushed
sometimes going up but we never had an
incident we always carried our car 15.
and but still yeah the local villagers
knew who we were sure the war was one at
that point uh and it's it's been an
episode of coin to phrase for it
we always win a battle
we never won a war
and it certainly happened that way ever
since World War II absolutely and then
at the when Uncle Wall came out with his
saying uh that we can't win this was at
a time
at the Ted offensive near the end of it
when every major battle had been won by
U.S forces now it took some time and way
was one of the bloodiest battle scenes
where the Marines fought you know Street
house to house the later first cab came
in other units and they took it yep and
at a great cost to the Communists More
Than Dirt but they just you know after
Uncle Walt said for losing it that was
the attitude that moved forward with it
that was a nail in the coffin oh yeah
well any other side notes on the Phoenix
project for you personally or no
um
it sounds like it's a program that
should have been carried on for years no
matter where we go yeah because that's a
structure or you work with local people
do
smoke out the kindness or the enemy
forces
and then to win the hearts and minds of
the people as you go forward to build
that Foundation against oppression yeah
these guys in in The Villages all they
wanted to do was to survive to have
something to eat to be able to feed
their families uh they had no ideology
and basically they were being kept from
that so you know they were pissed about
the whole thing and they were more than
happy when we rolled in and took the
village and didn't allow the people to
come in and take all their rides right
so they could feed some of the some of
the troops out there sure and then beat
up and abuser women yes exactly so and
uh just disgusting the um
um there was another point there oh it
went away so from the Phoenix project
what I like to do here John is to go
back to uh
see how a farm boy from Oklahoma
winds up in Special Forces and you
graduated from high school 19 1960 1960.
just for 17 years old and you said I had
enough of the farm and off you went to
an army recruiter yes I went to the Army
recruiter we had a hard hand who had
been in 101st Airborne during World War
II really so uh and he told me all the
stories about airborne and I thought Ah
that's what I want to do I want to go
out and jump out of airplanes and
everybody thought I was batshit crazy of
course
so I joined up
and went to uh went went through basic
obviously in the AIT and then went to
Fort Campbell and went through jump
school there it wasn't jump school a
little bit different at Fort Campbell
than what they had later yeah I went in
for example Fort Benning like my old
Barber
was 101st Airborne he said that they
used to have to
um
jump out of the Jeeps they were moving
and at some point they would have to the
physical training was much different
than what I went through in job school
so talk a little bit more about that
because that's a different
training regimen than what we had at
Fort Benning yeah for one thing they
didn't have the simulator
that they had at Fort Benning oh is that
right yeah yeah uh your your first time
under a parachute is when you fell off
an airplane right
and your day would be c-47s or flying
box cars right yeah
a little flying boss cars I'm told it
was a good jump I never it was a good
jump yeah yeah c-47 I never really had a
problem with uh the door's a little slow
a little bit it's a little low yeah you
have to you have to hunch down a bit but
uh but once you're out yeah you're out
so how long was Airborne training at
Fort Campbell uh through three weeks
also yeah three weeks and what was the
train like you had the first week well
there was a lot of uh plf uh obviously
and a lot of making sure you were in
good condition and PLS parachute Landing
Falls so that when you land yeah you
don't break a leg but you have your body
upon impact to take the full blow yeah
yeah the feet don't try not to do the
feed ass head the famous parachute
Landing fall right
um but uh and uh we did a lot of jumping
off of uh off of platforms and
practicing that of course and they had a
32 foot Tower down at a 32 foot Tower
and that was to make sure that you knew
that you had to get out that door well
again just for our listeners the 32-foot
Tower was 32 feet high you climb stairs
get up to the top and then from it they
had a cable and you hooked onto the
cable and you stood in the door an
instructor would say go yep and you had
to jump and you would fall a certain
distance and then go down that cable to
a burn but there are a lot of people who
couldn't do it oh yeah yeah 32 feet
there's something about that
psychological level I guess somebody
figured some shrinks are I must have
figured 32 feet is really a mind [__]
or something probably something like
that yeah because I remember at Jump
School seeing that seeing guys just
literally hang on to the door just
trying to push them out because you
can't get hurt you got the steel cable
and your back that's tied to the cable
it's going to take it to the Berm where
you have young men waiting to catch
catch you
so that was all there okay oh yeah and
so for now after jump School
film school I was was assigned to a
battalion uh and uh I don't know if
we'll want to go through the Charlie
Waters story or not uh I kind of like it
but maybe I think it was a confession
Charlie
um
they came around while I was there and
they're this guy who had ribbons that
would help clear up under his epaulette
and a totally unauthorized green boy
you know we didn't get our brain you
know yeah authorized so uh so he was uh
he was wearing un unapproved head care
uh and he got up there and started
talking about how this thing called the
Special Forces which I'd never heard of
and I don't think many other people had
and the book hadn't been out yet no Lord
no no a little aside I was on the I was
a medic on the uh Team there when when
he got put through the or Robin Moore
Robinson Robin Moore was the author
civilian who wrote the book The Green
Berets and and he got approval from
General uh Yarborough to do that only if
he would go through the training himself
he did he wrote about it and thousands
of men became Green Berets off of that
book I'm one yeah and I've talked to so
many over the years who said well if I
go to Vietnam I know I'm a city slicker
I need more training than just basic and
AIT indeed and Special Forces was the
place we got it it is yeah uh so it uh
so you're there Robin Moore you knew him
huh oh yeah yeah I was uh they would of
course they'd send all the officers out
on the last part of uh the course uh out
to the field up
field operations uh part of it and he
was on it and uh I could never figure
out where he was producing all those
bottles of whiskey
because every night those guys don't get
lit
okay moving right along to Charlie
Waters
yeah Charlie Waters uh was
Charlie Waters from the Bane to my
existence indeed uh a
first sergeant and 101st who had done a
marine on the guava canal and then got
out after the World War II joined back
up for Korea and became a ranger and
well decorated guy
tough uh tough as nails and he was my
first sergeant there in 101st he's the
one who convinced me to go on to Fort
Bragg because he'd probably kill me if
if I didn't well that's I didn't follow
orders very well
yeah and your discipline was you were
called into his office he closed the
door and beat this nail snot out of you
yeah well no he he let me put him up oh
sorry one of those where he used to
stand so you stand there and uh he
punches you no he let him put him up I
don't think I ever touched him he was
that good he was he was very good well
he had two Wars prior experience to you
being off the farm in Oklahoma so yeah
in terms of combat experience it really
wasn't fair but no it wasn't fair but it
was effective I'll say that so after the
second time he whooped you you finally
decided to do what I joined the Special
Forces with uh well you win
they said that was the main reason I
joined Special Forces they said they'd
get me out of Fort Campbell and kill me
but again in Fearless fairness to
Charlie he only did that if you got in
trouble downtown oh yeah being a young
oh I deserve a paratrooper yeah I
deserved it there's no Justified no
Justified discipline a little more harsh
than a little more harsh than that than
they do could you use the cry room
I'm sorry
that's today's discipline yeah that
would have been the latrine yeah
without as you're dabbing your face
you're trying to get stop the bleeding
oh Lord okay so you welcome to Fort
Bragg you why you arrived there Rob
there uh God put in I had a high score
on practically everything so they
decided I needed to go to Como school I
lasted about two days on that and that
did it on that stuff just didn't cut it
for me
so they they were talking about some I
heard some of the guys talking about you
know if you want to be a medic uh you'll
go down to Fort Sam Houston for basic
and advanced Aid Man training and Fort
Sam Houston is full of female soldiers
well I'm 18 years old yes uh so you can
really mature now yeah
so yeah I was more mature than I wasn't
17 anyway uh so so that sounded good to
me uh so well I went uh to become a
medic and met this big tall
uh Louisiana girl who was also there
being medic and 60 years later we're
still together yes I mean just a week
ago and a day you celebrated your 60th
anniversary we did she still talks to
you she still loves you and uh well I'm
not sure of the latter part but
gracious this morning at breakfast we'll
say that
and so
uh getting getting back to the medic
side of things just for the record the
Green Berets at that time became through
that program they developed the program
which was the best medic training in the
world oh so the green Brave Medics at
that time throughout the Vietnam War and
since still remain
the best Medics which are close to a
year of training everything from uh
colds dealing with Medics medicine to
severe combat wounds how to treat them
and uh
um maybe you could talk just a little
bit well first you were attracted to it
but then people don't realize the
rigorous
of the rigors study programs you had to
go through because
um
every day you would get a lot of
information
if you could talk just a little bit
letter or viewers see what that was like
I was like drinking from a fire hose oh
okay yeah they're throwing these at you
how to treat people and every yeah every
decision on demand really had to you had
to know uh you had to know symptoms you
had to know uh how to treat it how both
palliative treatment and possibly uh
full treatment
so and you're talking about 50 or 60
diseases out there that you were likely
to incur
um so and you you didn't have
didn't have a smartphone no you couldn't
call anybody up from out there and just
know just the other side of Cambodia
indeed
so all that stuff had to be in your head
yeah uh your only reference was a Merc
manual and a uh a uh Anatomy book and
for our readers The Merc manual is
remark manual is it lifts all the
diseases and basically is point by point
it's about it's about six inches thick I
remember it could be used for physical
training it has a weight to it yeah oh
my God but you guys knew it and we
basically we knew it yeah you didn't
have time to you're there you're trying
to treat somebody who's going into
convulsions uh you don't have time to
pull out the old Merc Mountain don't
figure out what the hell is this
no that's true and then also you would
get daily tests and then weekly tests if
you feel any you're out out yeah
yeah there was no there was no
Second Chance in it yeah not the other
I've had a couple of really good SF
medic friends who talked about how
um
at night even if they're going through
the grueling classes I mean when we had
our comma class and the MOS training
there was a lot we had a lot more
flexibility in the medic training hand
and I just can't imagine you guys at
night would be back and they would be
like studying hard oh yeah the day's
notes yeah because it because weekends
nights uh the rest of the world didn't
exist right uh you you were on that book
and you were working with somebody else
hopefully I worked with a guy named Gary
Jones uh who also made it through uh
Gary and I would sit there and quiz each
other and he'd pick something out and
say okay this is Dengue fever uh tell me
about it and you better be able to tell
about it because when you took that test
on Friday you're writing all that down
and it better be complete if you didn't
you flown anything you forgot you'd pay
a price for it you yep and then um
eventually
um so that was 16 weeks of Fort Sam
and local hospitals uh and they put us
into every Ward they was including psych
which people probably thought I belonged
but they uh I mean OBGYN the whole
business oh yeah yeah and uh one of one
of the things I got to do uh that I
really enjoyed was the doctor down on
emergency would let me do let me do the
stitching oh really yeah you're good at
sewing them up oh wow
came in very handy later indeed because
I remember our Medics at fubai at one
point they delivered a lot of babies
but that was part of the SF thing even
with SOG we had a village nearby and we
would work with any of the locals and
that would be part of the hearts of Mind
program to work with them help their
families medical wise and things like
that yeah and the Medics were the point
personally and of course
um when we'll get into your first tour
and second tour a little bit talk about
what it was like being a medic on those
teams but so for your medic training
then after that there's the dog lab
which over the years has had a high
degree of controversy from we won't even
name the organization but there's a
reason why there was a dog lab and the
reason why and what kind of training was
that for you it was that was the
surgical lab uh that was the part where
you actually treated a wound and you had
combat yeah combat wound uh and the dog
and we're using dogs at the time they
weren't quite as politically conscious
as we are today yeah but you had to have
lives flesh uh so what are you going to
shoot yeah you're going to go out you're
going to go get a free dog because the
Army wasn't making a lot of money in
those days however go buy a pig or a
bunch of pigs yeah uh so we'd go to the
local uh pound and pick out a good sized
dog you couldn't pick up some little
yapper right uh then bring them back in
and exercise them one of the instructors
would uh would shoot into the upper
thigh uh avoiding the bone right
and then it was your job
to treat that wound keep that dog alive
uh for the rest of that week entire week
for the entire week
and if you did not you flown
I have that dog died you were out
and you said also you couldn't use
antibiotics no antibiotics no so what
would the treatment be I'm a girl guy
now so help me out here a little bit
purely purely using uh iodine and swabs
and keep it clean yeah keeping keeping
the wound clean the breeding any part of
it the first thing you do is go in and
you test flesh and see if it's still
alive okay how do you do that uh you
would pick it up and test test it for uh
flexibility elasticity yeah uh and if
it's uh if it's if it's loose and it's
flopping that's got to come off of there
right uh because it will that's that's
your focus for infection you could have
been a flesh inspector yeah
okay so a week later and again we should
emphasize that this training is what led
to the Green Beret Medics being the best
in the world because in combat
you could treat any wound anyone and
that enabled us to keep our people rsf
as well as our indigenous people alive
during combat yeah you got to remember
that the the SF medic and special forces
in itself
the original idea was that special
forces was designed to go Behind Enemy
Lines and in case the balloon ever went
up and organize equipped train gorillas
in Bella Russia or
Russia itself or like World War II with
the OSS Behind Enemy Lines well let's
ask Behind Enemy Lines it's part of our
heritage yep uh and you go you're back
there and somebody gets wounded one of
your people gets wounded you're not
going to take him to the local hospital
because they're going to kill him yeah
so you've got to treat all the wounds
there and you've got to treat the
diseases that uh that are pandemic to
those areas and you're not going to get
it outside assistance you may
occasionally get an oversight package in
it but that'd be about the extent of it
and the packages would just be medicines
basically right and more bandages yep
but maybe a couple of body bags yeah so
you had to so you had to have that
ability to do that and completely
austere
and this is all part of your training uh
as an enlisted man at that time correct
so
um so the total time you're in medic
training was approximately a year yeah
yeah it's a little over that because
then when you're done then you go back
to brag and then you go through uh the
training there wrapping it up with a
field training exercise yeah FTX where
FDX yeah that's the last phase of
training where it's like three weeks
and you work together as an 18 for the
first time the traditional 18 which has
an officer executive officer they run
the team but then you have a team
sergeant and then you have five Moss two
Medics senior Junior two combo two demo
uh two engineers
weapons and
um
Intel yeah and Intel and so that would
be the team the way it would work yep
and uh so
you graduate from that and then before
long welcome to Vietnam and you got
there early got there in February of
1963. wow uh they were they were
starting to expand special forces in
Vietnam before that there had been very
few there there had been the occasional
team here and there but this was the
start of the entire hearts and Minds uh
exercise
so we were starting new camps all over
the place ours was up at uh up on the
Cambodian border you could almost spit
into Cambodia is that right yeah
uh and the reason why it was there was a
heck of infiltration room sure they they
were coming through there and it was
almost straight if you look at locked in
and on the map that peninsula there or
that
terrain there basically is an arrow on
the heart of Saigon
so that was extremely important we got
there while the French were still there
really they had plantations all over the
place rubber for the most part sure they
had uh up the hill from where we had to
Camp they had a uh an entire go-to Club
there where they had swimming pool they
had you could go to go to their bar and
have a drink yeah of course they were
supplying the Intel from the DC we knew
that but they would occasionally give us
a little decent the Intel too well the
French were also paying the Vietcong oh
of course protection money so that the
Vietcong would not harm them or their
their rubber trees yep exactly so it's
again another little sidebar yeah it's
uh to the extent that we had to build
our camp in the absolutely the worst
possible spot that you could have had up
there in a valley somewhere in a valley
uh rubber trees all around you right uh
and you could not shoot outside that
camp unless you were actually attacked
because you might hit a rubber tree no
oh yeah
yeah our restrictions were pretty pretty
ridiculous we talked about stupid Rules
of Engagement it sounds like the
epitomization is that same yeah pretty
much
we uh we got we got uh we had a patrol
out uh and this goes back to the medic
part uh we had a patrol out and they got
shot up pretty bad so we brought them
back into camp and of course first thing
they do is triage
uh you put them in categories these are
guys who will wait because it's minor
these are guys who you'll treat now
because if you don't treat them now they
die they die these are the guys it
doesn't matter how much you treat
they're probably going to die
so we did that and we I'm being a senior
medic worked our asses off most of that
night and there was one guy over the
side who had been put in that side for
probably a good reason he taking a round
up under his nose and had taken the
front part of his head off
this girl off
somebody who's still alive
so being this arrogant Young
medic that I am
I bet I can keep him alive
so after we had everything else done uh
I'm over there and I went into
convulsions so I give him something for
convulsions it goes down too far I gave
him something to bring him back up from
that we went through that seesaw all
night uh and the next day he was still
alive we evacuated him finally got a
plane in there up on the runway
evacuated him and went down to Saigon
and I thought at the end of that he'll
go to yeah yeah he died when I went back
on the second tour he was a gate guard
at Camp Goodman no yeah
and again that was is that from the
Ambush where after you all have been
there for a while it was we'd been we'd
been there for a while but it was before
the Ambush okay that another conflict
yeah the
the one we were talking about there is
where we were getting ready to be
replaced our tour was opposite because
year was be coming again at that time uh
stick company was going to take the
right and then uh fifth Special Forces
Group was sending people in TDY which is
temporary Duty for six months yeah at
that time right they didn't they didn't
get deployed on mass until 65 right so
yeah it was teams teams reflecting teams
uh our team came in they'd been there a
couple of days probably and we
one of the things that was a great
success story for us was the Outreach
that we did medical Outreach that we did
to these various Villages
we'd take uh some of the young Medics
that we had trained the the we didn't
have any Vietnamese we had cambodians at
that time was that right yeah they were
all cam bugs how were they uh they were
great uh probably little suckers uh but
we'd we'd go out with that on deuce and
a half loaded with supplies uh one of us
one of the two Medics would go out with
it we alternated days on that and we'd
go to the village and we'd start
creating people and we'd Lions would
form probably of 20 30 people long and
you're there trying to take care of
these people and give them what they
need whether it be a drug or whether
they're sewing something up or pulling a
tooth I probably pulled more tooth teeth
in that six month there in in in Vietnam
how many babies did you deliver uh only
delivered two two more than me
[Laughter]
oh my gosh but our Intel Sergeant would
be on Down the Line somewhere and he'd
be talking to these villagers there and
asking them just innocuous questions he
could talk the language yeah wow uh and
that he would get these uh so we'd
gather all kinds of good Intel about
what was going on in The Villages and
everything else and again we can compare
that to the to the Communist tactics
which would come in with weapons we're
taking over your village give us your
food oh come here sweetheart rape the
women whereas the Green Berets come in
they work with the Villagers and it
could be everything from something as
fundamental as we have a stream of water
coming through your village have the
poop pot Downstream not Upstream please
move it something basically like that
too true to doing complete surgery
delivering uh babies things like that
indeed our biggest enemy though were the
traditional healers uh because oh is
that right yeah oh yeah they they saw us
that's up starts we didn't know Chinese
medicine we didn't know this you know
and some of the stuff that they were
doing like cupping uh what like cupping
for muscle uh injuries
they burn a piece of cotton in a ceramic
cup and put it on on a bruise or
anything like that yeah and what that
does is it sucks the it sucks basically
sucks the uh the blood out blood out oh
no kidding yeah and you see that in NBA
now that so you know you know it works
yeah it works I was uh I was a little
skeptic of it at that point sure but but
in any case that's that's what we did
that's one of these you had to juggle in
the field yeah
so we
that day it was my senior medic he took
the took the team out uh to this to this
Village that we'd visited several times
before uh unbeknownst to us the the VC
had decided they didn't like the fact
that we were doing that and Gathering
Intel and turning the village around so
they wouldn't be supportive you were
winning hearts and Minds don't like that
yeah no they do not so they set up a
they set up an ambush in a the only road
that came in and out of there
well in the main and they had intended
basically to shoot up our medical team
and kill the medic kill Sergeant there
but
as chance had it our new command the new
Commander Captain Mosher wanted to see
one of these so he and my my commander
Captain uh
uh jumped in a jeep along with uh
Goodman the first sergeant Goodman
jumped in the Jeep and away they went
well the VC saw a target of opportunity
and they let loose on them uh Captain
mosh was killed immediately uh Sergeant
Goodman took a took a bullet through the
back of the head killed immediately uh
Sergeant or Captain Hackley was he had
been wounded he got it got into a ditch
and was trying to return fire and they
threw a grenade in on him and that was
the end of the story wow so they have
been driving in the Jeep when they when
they opened fire in a Jeep and they
didn't have any other protections just
them no other production right no
sidearms right this is 1963. 1963 they
were the 64th through 68th Americans
killed in Vietnam wow
so um that tour Duty ends you come back
to the States back to brag back Greg and
it looked to me like I was going to be
on detail after detail uh picking up
pine cones and uh mowing lawns you know
in those days you had to be a master
sergeant to get a power mower
everybody else push mowers or sling
blades
so I decided I didn't really want that
and they were asking for volunteers to
go out to Language School ah I'm at
school yeah becoming cunning linguist
yes indeed so I went out to Monterey and
took French for six months oh wow
Monterey yeah it was it was great that's
still one of the best schools around oh
it is yeah yes well it could be why I
went to Monterey again and studied
Russian and then went to Monterey again
and studied Spanish was that right yeah
you became a regular out there in
between tourism
Duty
there's this another train you forced
upon yourself besides going to OCS and
becoming a lieutenant
um you went to Ranger oh yeah ranger
training in the dead of winter dead
winter winter Ranger God
um I didn't learn anything
that I didn't already know
so I I thought you know you've just put
yourself into eight weeks of misery
and it was it was miserable but I got
the tab you got the details that was
really important Flair huh yes is that
right no no
so after ranger training at some point
you go back to the seventh group and
then
1967 actually I went to the newly formed
third group The Australia and they had
moved the fifth out and they were
setting up Special Forces Group now
their headquarters was in the train yeah
so the entire group was there their main
focus was Vietnam and then for SOG we
were detached excuse me from
headquarters but we had all our
Personnel records of things that were
handled there but our direct chain of
command would go through Saigon and then
what about your um
your chain of command like when you had
an operation gone you reported directly
to the CIA then about your missions or
who you're working with who when you're
with the Phoenix project who where was
your second base would uh I would
provide that to our
uh royk our regional officer in charge
uh he and yes he was agency right I
don't know if his active agency or not
but he certainly was agency you never
can tell them yeah we're badges no I'd
I'd heard somewhere later on that the
Roger McCarthy was his name I'd heard
somewhere later on that he was one of
the last people and one of the many
coups that they'd had in Bolivia last
people running for aircraft and shooting
as he goes
[Laughter]
okay so your second tour Duty you land
in the two core two core and uh so
Benton the central Highlands area and
again you get another one of these these
camps that fortunately the Seabees built
the a camp yeah all on the ground again
yeah yeah that was uh that was that was
Venton uh the Venton Valley was a known
Corridor for North Vietnamese coming
down uh the new yellow star division
basically made their home there and that
was one of the one of their top
divisions in in those days the yellow
star division I've never heard yeah okay
yellow star uh I don't know what number
they were but they went by that
that they the
101st had been oh not the 101st sorry
first the first Cav had been through
there and they had said they had cleaned
it all out and everything else and we're
still getting mortared and rocketed uh
practically every day and you know if
you cleaned it out that's uh that's
pretty hard to do
[Laughter]
but uh the uh We've
one of the things that that convinced me
that there were a lot more people out
there than what they were saying was
that we had a Recon small Recon outfit
with one of my ncos go up into one of
The Valleys there and they set up they
hear somebody coming so they set up an
improve prompt to ambush
and here come these guys bopping down
the trail no care in the world so they
trigger the Ambush kill all the people
start to grab all their stuff and head
back into camp well uh we uh we start
looking through it and one of the things
they have is the site for a 120
millimeter mortar
wow uh now 120 doesn't come in anything
unless in the regimental size unit
was that right yeah
so oh we knew that there were there were
bad guys out there and this part of
pontoon area or two core I mean two
years earlier in 1965 that's where the
first Cav was bloodied yeah at the I
drank Valley yeah and of course the
first battle with the movie was based on
We Were Soldiers once
um that was the first confrontation
between U.S troops army versus the North
Vietnamese Army and they had been
entrenched which nobody realized again
due to poor and Intel until they get on
the ground and they're fighting for
their lives so this area had been hotly
contested and of course the other
sidebar after the the first battle of
the I drank the Second Battle they
really got hurt
so two years later there's still a lot
of enemy activity and here comes your
recon patrols out they get Intel saying
oh there's a 120 this there's a bigger
unit coming and the first Cav reaction
to that was what sir yeah the first cab
reaction yeah they poop hooted oh that's
leftovers there we've been through that
area so many times there's nobody left
out there
uh okay uh that's uh that's fine but
they said because you guys are probably
scared out there uh we will send a
company out and we will check things out
well they sent the company out they
landed them up on top of top of one of
the mountains out there uh their mortar
platoon they left down in a saddle in
between those mountains and they went
out patrolling
well the North Vietnamese came in there
and Savaged that platoon uh killed most
of them killed two journalists which I
don't think is that much of a loss but
I have bad bad history with journalists
indeed
um but they uh but then you had one of
the cab generals flyover and they he
said well ain't this the craziest damn
horse I ever rode so that became
operation Crazy Horse and one of web
grip not web Griffin uh WB no uh no the
other writer oh
uh the one who's written all the books
about
it'll come to us yeah but he wrote uh he
wrote a book about uh about this
particular operation so then it was all
in the cab was cab was there uh they had
the Koreans coming from the coast they
had to know Vietnamese division that was
there and by God we've got it surrounded
not in the first place you ain't
surrounding any place up in the
mountains like that no uh but they were
convinced as he did now we need to know
where they are
so we're going to take four Special
Forces teams uh and we're going to put
them on the ground yeah we're going to
put them on the ground and they're going
to find them and fix them and then we'll
come in and annihilate them
okay so so guess who's out there again
no oh yeah you're trying to pinpoint a
battalion trying to pinpoint a lot more
in the Battalion is that right how big
do you think it was it there was almost
a it was a full regiment and they were
still they were still bringing people in
yeah of course yeah it was uh and they
they were very good at laying low until
the right time uh I don't think that the
American Army ever really understood
that
they they
finally got to doing some Recon much
later on in training some people to do
Recon before that it was just stumble
until you had until you find somebody oh
my God uh so you're you're four units go
out and they found somebody oh yeah we
uh we we look up this Hillside and we're
in the elephant grass and I look up this
Hillside and there it's an open area
before you get just for uh elephant
grass is grass that's thick it's bladed
and it can be anywhere from three to
four feet to 10 to 12 feet exactly and
moving through it is noisy it cuts you
up if you don't have gloves on yep it
will it's just nasty yeah it's uh and so
you landed in that and now you and you
can't be too clandestine because anybody
within half a mile will see the elephant
grass we'll hear them you're trampling
it down but yeah you're going through
there so yeah you're building a trail
form uh so they know exactly where you
are well we get up to this one
Mountainside that's clear about halfway
up out of the elephant grass and then
the tree line is there and we start
receiving a little bit of fire from
there so my uh my company Commander if
you see my Vietnamese company Commander
so
buku VC
all right let's get them
is that right I'm I'm not saying I'm the
smartest guy in the world yeah yeah
but yeah
we we started assaulting uh and started
taking some casualties as you can
imagine uh and couldn't one of my one of
the things I hated was that I didn't
have America another medic out with me
so I couldn't do anything for them at
the point
and get about halfway up that thing and
out of the tree line and I realized uh
we're gonna we're rocking a hard place
here uh we go back down uh they're going
to shoot us uh they're going to come
down in another run you overrun us we'll
stay here and they're going to treat us
so we got to assault when in doubt
charge that's it uh
hey I can't imagine so we're done yeah
I've done a lot of of uh training with
these guys on laying them down a base
with an element laying down a base of
fire keeping the enemy head down
fire maneuver uh and they were following
her to a T and so we got up close where
we could actually see the guys in holes
and start taking them out and I was
throwing grenades and that scene we
happened to book was is that the one we
fixed quote fictionalized but it's
actually this is the real deal it was
the real deal yeah
uh and one funny part of that whole
thing if any good thing about it can be
funny is that I'd run out of grenades
so the yard funny yeah the yards were
throwing me their grenades because I
could throw them further yeah
they don't have so I'm throwing those
grenades and uh and then I see that
there's some of them starting to roll a
little bit back down so I started
cooking them off right uh one second two
second throw
and they would go off when they were
supposed to and that impressed the [__]
out of the Yards so so the problem was
that they decided they would make it
easier on the lieutenant they'd pull the
pen throw the spoon and come off they
throw it to me and I'm here scrambling
from that damn grenade
thank goodness don't do this anymore
yeah
I'll take care of the spoon and just for
our listeners that aren't familiar you
have a hand grenade that has a firing
device and there's a there's literally a
spoon that wraps around it but it has a
pin you pull the pin out the spoon pops
off that ignites The Detonator that's a
five second fuse
and when that comes off you have five
seconds to get rid of your grenade so
for the Monte yours is take it off throw
you through the grid now it's live it's
ticking down you've got to catch it and
get rid of it before you get this route
from your grenade yeah yeah and our
grenades were very good very deadly yeah
they are very deadly yeah there's no
question about that I don't know so much
about the baseball grenades that they
have now but certainly the ones we had
then oh absolutely yeah that's right so
was this the mission where
um you were seriously wounded by a
remote controlled detonation no that was
later uh that was later on later in that
tour due to your second tour yeah okay
so moving right along then the house
what goes along what led to the mission
where you wound up getting seriously
wounded we were always doing patrols uh
if nothing else to then to keep them off
their uh keep them off the bounce yeah
keep them keep them on notice that we
were out there and I'd run anything from
a platoon to a company and that's one
case we knew who arise cash was we'd
gotten Intel on that so we went to the
rice cache and you ever tried to destroy
about 2 000 pounds of rice no you can't
not even with Napalm no
snap crackle pop we enjoyed ourselves by
pissing at it yeah
laughs but then we're coming back to
going back to Camp uh and the I always
kept flanks out when we had a
company-sized unit out there sure
because you can maneuver that way if you
could hit on one side you can maneuver
on at least two other sides same thing
with it and that's the fundamentals of
Patrol with the large unit exactly
flight security yeah but people being
what they are security Fields like it
should be in close to another person so
inevitably those flags would start
inching in and I'd raise hell with them
and call them every name that there was
and get them out and then go and then in
bed doing it all and you're in the
jungle at this point or like no I'm out
in the opening totally and they open it
so you really want them spread out yeah
um so I've just gotten back from one of
those tirades that I'd given and I had
walked into the column which the center
column was one mat after another you
didn't want to spread out because better
chance hitting something that you don't
want to hit mine or something
so I ordinarily walked no more than two
uh to Three Men Behind point because I
wanted to be able to see what the action
was and react to it intelligently sure
not from behind there somewhere where
everybody everything's going on up in
front
but I'd gotten back in and I was
circling around to get back up to my
position I'd gotten up to position six I
think it was and the whole world just
went boom uh and next thing I realized
I'm lying on my back and I'm bleeding
from virtually everywhere I can't hear a
thing and everything looks like it's a
haze is that right yeah and I thought
I'm dead yeah
[Laughter]
about five seconds and then I looked
again and I'm still bleeding wait a
minute
I know enough of a medic to know but you
can't bleed if you're dead
I'm alive but I'm bleeding I can't see
very well and that's because they had a
detonated a remote control detonation of
a mine yeah it was uh basically it was
designed on the the similarly to our
Claymore where you're throwing out a
bunch of pellets at very rapid speeds
that will pull through anything yeah uh
so they they did their own which was
take a barrel lid and make a concave
put C4 or RDX or whatever they had all
over the face of it and then stick every
piece of metal that they could find into
it and uh and detonate it and it would
have had a killing radius of probably 30
feet wow on so it was uh pretty pretty
nasty it wiped out my first three people
they were they were dead on rival
the fourth one uh died of wounds uh the
fifth one was was wounded as well as I
was had you been in your normal spot you
would have been careful dead yeah yeah
no question about that wow uh so they
medevaced me and take me into uh into
quenion the field Hospital there and I'm
lying on the gurney and I'm hearing a
plink plink if they're taking pieces of
metal out of me you're dropping the
emesis pan oh my gosh
they give me anesthetic did you bring
any home for souvenirs no I didn't have
that I wasn't in the mood for seven
years that day but you're on the
stretcher huh I have enough souvenirs
when I pull my shirt off
oh you're just riddled with the stuff oh
yeah yeah some of it was Bones from the
people in front of me sure yeah blown
all sorts of crap on me a lot of the
blood was from people in front of me oh
man
so uh eventually get inside the hospital
and they just had one of those unique
moments in time where I guess you really
haven't talked about that much but at
one point there was a nurse who's kind
of like chuckling at you or something
I'm sorry I just really you just got to
go down this bumpy Trail
to nurses chucking at you yeah we had uh
we had a charge nurse she was in charge
of all the all the rest of the nurses
right uh and she I thought she was an
old woman of course I'm at that time
what 22. at least yeah yeah she's
probably in her 30s so she has to be an
old woman Yeah by your yeah any
listeners uh I don't not prejudice
against 30 year old women no no
I've been married for 60 years thank you
that's it
but she was uh while I was laying there
on she was sort of
trying to stifle a laugh and I'm
wondering what the hell is she laughing
about and by now you're all you're all
drugged up with painting oh yeah you
can't kill anything yeah I don't feel
much of anything yeah you're just happy
to be alive yeah and why is this damn
nurse chuckling at me yes
well I found out uh he I asked the
doctor about it uh and he said uh I
didn't really want to talk to you about
this right now but
uh and don't worry
uh but you took there's no brain damage
you know brain damage yeah that was
brain damage
I thought my wife accused me up anyway
um
that he said you've taken three of those
pellets right through your penis
and we embedded in your thigh so don't
worry nothing has other else has been
affected uh you'll maintain and all
everything that you need to maintain
indeed and then he gave me another shot
and I was gone at that point but later
that night I'm up in the ward and this
charge nurse comes by one of those
moments in time oh she uh uh she she has
this whole gaggle of nurses behind her I
think it's probably ever nursed in that
hospital
she comes up there she throws the covers
off of me yeah and says girls have you
ever seen a dick like this
but now it's swollen oh it's swollen
about three times it's a proper size
move over trigger we got a new horse we
got a new stud here
oh my God welcome to Vietnam yeah that
insult to injury one of my one of my
ncos several days later yeah comes down
and uh he's seeing how I am and
everything and he's brought a bottle of
whiskey with him of course of course so
we're uh we're
satellite we're taking a few sips of
that I think you didn't like did you
start the leak uh I'm sorry no but
no but uh and this Sergeant bearing
typical Special Forces indeed you know
sensitive and kind of kind of yeah
absolutely I forgot the second part yeah
yeah he uh he says tell me
how do you piss out of that thing you
play it like a piccolo
I got called that name for years that
became Piccolo you pick a little that
became because of the instrument indeed
making fun of your instrument of Love
yeah yes indeed that's all right I got
him later oh did you same camp okay we
uh you're able to go back to the camper
oh yeah I went back there no yeah yeah
then caught malaria and I was gone again
well then he got really sick yeah yeah
for a month on that oh uh but then went
back to the camp and we had two ncos
there that hated each other's guts uh
and they'd get into fist fights for no
apparent reason and just tear [__] up
all over the place until you know one of
them declared
he won and the other one would say okay
next time
so it disrupted the whole camp and my
commander there the captain says you
used to be an NCO get those two
straightened out so here I am between
these guys and they're both they're
probably four inches taller than I am
really yeah okay and I'm between them
and I said I'm gonna whip your ass if
you keep this up and they look at me
just laugh
but one of them
you know I told you about the latrine up
on the rights up there yeah so one of
them was in there doing his duty one day
gets up to leave uh latrine had a spring
door on it of course to keep the flies
out as much as possible uh you know as
he goes out that door slaps him in the
ass and his 45 goes off no and a
carnival groove right down his leg
and I uh so he comes there and I take
him to the dispensary I said I'll take
care of this I took him to dispensary
and I'm swabbing out the wound and
putting stuff on it and bandaging and
everything and I said
here's thanks snake
I'm going to put you in for the Purple
Heart for this
and he said oh God damn you can't do
that
I said yes I can and I will oh and
everybody in Vietnam by the time I get
through will know that you got your
Purple Heart by getting shot by a
[__]
was that snake Adams no no no
snake another snake
oh God you can't do that I said there's
one one condition you apply for a
transfer somewhere else I'm tired of
trying to get between you two [__]
he was gone the next day
that's efficiency
oh my God all right well so anything
more from your second tour we've gone
through the third tour and then I wanted
to shift gears
um
you had your the last 10 years of your
time in the military because you're in
for a total of 22 years so after that
maybe just give us a quick cursory yeah
I had to go back uh the Infantry
Advanced course uh after the last tour
right uh that's almost a year they teach
you how to be a
Battalion Commander supposedly uh you
know teaching World War II tactics right
and the Vietnam war is still going on
World War II tests yeah that's very good
so mostly with our army mostly we just
stay drunk
the then decided hey I just I want to go
back to Monterey so applaud that far and
got Russian language school and went out
there and spent a year and that set me
up then to go to bad tilts uh to First
Battalion in the 10th Special Forces
great at that time and just for our
listening all these bad toast was the
first assignment outside the U.S where
the Green Berets went in 1952 53. the SF
Originals went over they trained left on
a boat from Wilmington North Carolina
went to Germany took a train maybe a
second train and then they marched into
battles and bad told that the Cold War
was going on at the time oh Russians bad
toll side of History all its own that
was the SS officer surely right I forgot
that yeah
and the SS is just so again for our
listeners that are young today this is
the German SS
yeah
um so I spent four years there learn to
ski and that's another story in itself I
just come out of Southeast Asia right
yeah it wasn't exactly uh quality of
rice paddies yeah not much skiing even
in the central Highlands yeah
so but everybody had to learn to ski
because that was if the balloon ever
went up which everybody knew it wasn't
but if it ever did that was going to be
one of our methods of getting past the
enemy going and going back into where we
were going to set up these gorillas uh
so everybody had to learn to ski and
what a circus that was they had these
old white star skis that were they
seemed to be about 11 feet long they
weren't quite that but they were very
narrow uh no they were quite wide was
that right yeah they were quite right
and they uh the the clamps on them you
could put your ankle on the ground
before that damn thing would cut an edge
uh and and Wolverine boots and no ski
boats just Wolverine boats oh and that's
how we were that's how we were skiing
yeah it's ridiculous
so what was fun though was we always had
a ski March at least once a year after
we got good snow and that was going up
one mountain using moleskin uh on the
bottom of them to go up the mountain uh
and then taking that off and skiing down
the next slope and then going back up
the next mountain and down the next
slope well that next slope was they had
a guest house right down at the bottom
of it and the Germans somehow had found
out what our schedule was
so what we were scheduled to come down
that last Mountain a place was packed
everybody drinking beer and cheering us
on and everything yeah the reason being
that it was disaster city as we were
coming down that last
we had it looked like snow explosions
were going off we'll sleep entertainment
oh yeah for the locals at your expense
hahaha
oh my gosh
so then uh 22 years then what happens
there about 22 years I uh tried to get a
job somewhere in Corporate America found
out pretty quickly that Corporate
America didn't have a lot of use my
peculiar skills and the mafia wasn't
hiring right so uh so I went to Saudi
Arabia and worked there for three years
training the Saudi Arabian National
Guard oh wow came back to the States and
thought well I'll get an MBA and then
somebody will hire me I got an MBA
nobody heard me
so but have you started writing yet at
that point no I hadn't started at that
point no I had so at that point then the
the the the the
various agencies Came Calling the
three-letter alphabet soups that didn't
work for them at first uh the first one
was the anti-terrorism assistance
program it was run by the state
department right it was basically
Aviation Security because that was when
we were all worried about and more
hijackings and dropping airplanes and
where they shouldn't be right so I
worked there for a couple of years and I
went to work for isitab international
criminal investigative training and
assistance program common spelling yeah
yeah and it was it was primarily
oriented towards the drug wars and it
was uh it was
this is in Southeast Asia or South
America or South America okay yeah and I
spoke Spanish by then right if your
third trip fourth trip to uh yeah to
Monterey okay yep uh
yeah so I've spent a lot of time in uh
down south uh in Colombia in particular
Columbia our mission was to protect the
judges they were and to train their
judicial police to protect the judges
because they were getting killed on a
rate of about one a week yeah uh that
was a time when Joseph was really a
judge they would try to eliminate yeah
exactly uh so they asked me to put
together a team to go down there and
train their people and in the meantime
do some security surveys try to figure
out how to
Harden their uh their houses their
offices and so forth
so I put together a team I had three
former Secret Service guys which was my
biggest mistake and three three SF guys
so awful one to Colombia and we're
trying to train these guys and the
Secret Service guys their idea of a
motorcade is at least four limousines
and a Chase car right these guys are
taking a bus to work oh really yeah it
didn't really work well no
so we fought that battle over and over
again at one uh but the uh but we we
would go into their houses and we'd tell
them these are the things you need to
look for these are the signs uh and oh
by the way that propane tank that you
have sitting out there in front of your
house very conveniently located with the
nozzle
going through the fence so that when
they fill the propane up they don't have
to go into your yard
oh yeah
slap me a charge on that and I'll take
out the block oh yeah uh they uh that's
the kind of thing we had to deal with
when we first got there State Department
said okay we've got a vehicle for you
I love you okay
so they took us out to this old suburban
uh and it seems better days and it's the
old style Suburban where he didn't have
fuel injection uh it's carburetor now
you're at six thousand feet right
uh that thing had a top speed of about
20 miles an hour
so no I don't think we're going to take
that so what we do is take taxis
we'd go on different plugs in different
different place uh split up take a taxi
take it wherever we were going join back
up at that point take taxes from there
we were just you know everybody thinks
of South America and Mexico unless
you've actually been there as being
typical swore the uh
pull complexion Colombia a lot of times
you can't tell the difference between an
American and a Colombian no kids oh yeah
lots of German immigrants there's lots
of lots of French so we were just one
more person in a taxi
yeah so we uh never never had an issue
Blended right in yeah no problem there
was one incident I had Das was their
equivalent of the FBI and the CIA all
together
uh debate Department
administrative administrative
uh they uh and they had a building that
there was their headquarters uh it was
all glass uh it was about eight stories
tall and it was in the middle of a
parking lot
uh where people could drive up anytime
any day
so I did my study on this and I said the
first thing you got to do is to either
get rid of these windows or put at least
put mylar on them so when they come out
they'll come out in one piece if you get
an explosion the way they are they're
going to be missiles that are going to
cut you to pieces oh yeah oh yes yes yes
we will do this we will do this then I
said the next thing you need to do is
shut that parking lot don't let any
vehicle come in there that is not
authorized yes yes that will be harder
but we will do that
so I'm going back out there for my final
uh
final session with them and in a in the
cab and this cab driver has taken me
every detour that you can think of in
Bogota running up his tab yeah of course
uh so and I'm brow beating him God damn
it I've got a meeting out here in
spanish of course yeah I got a meeting
out here I got to be at that and he just
looks in the rear view and grins who can
takes another detour
oh we get about two blocks away from dos
and the world goers oh uh and I knew
what had happened uh and there was no
question about it they had pulled a bus
school bus into that parking lot filled
with info and had blown it whoa killed
80 some people in the building wounded
practically everybody most of it from
flying glass
no the crater from that thing was
about 30 feet deep and tell you how to
force that thing was
wow 30 feet yep so I jumped out of the
cab and gave him the best tip that he
probably ever had every peso I had you
had to be late oh yeah I was real happy
because Peter got me there on time I'd
have been in that parking lot oh my God
so I'm up there waiting in blood coming
up over my shoes trying to trying to
help people yeah and it just it was it
was horrible the medical skills medic
skills
yeah high gear yeah wow okay so going
along at some point
um
you turn into an author yes what what uh
what sparked this I've always wanted to
be an author
forms of Oklahoma when I was eight years
old I was writing pornographic novels
for my schoolmates
I didn't know anything about it yeah of
course but I had a good imagination uh
fertile
but it went uh but then of course life
intruded and I always wanted to write
and I'd jot down things from here and
there and of course I had plenty of time
in Saudi Arabia so I wrote my first very
failed novel there and reading it a few
years later I realized why I was failed
oh God that's terrible
so you're self-taught you don't go out
and talk to award-winning authors say
hey I got this great idea just like
typical SFS and let's just jump into
this just jump into it I see something
like this book uh I'm driving along and
we would instead of elephant grass we've
got Johnson grass there in Oklahoma I'm
driving along and it's the same effect
that Johnson grass is waving in that
wind and it just brought back those
memories so sharp we're talking about
days of fire yep indeed from earlier and
so I had to I just had to get it down on
the paper so I wrote the first chapter
and then I thought yeah [__] so uh
some time later they're having a having
a convention in D.C and Mark Barrett's
there and you know Mark is quite a
successful author and I was telling him
about this story and he said uh
you can you're no judge of your own
writing uh clean it up a little bit send
it to this guy and see what he thinks
that guy's Jim Morris no yeah he was at
that time he was at pocketbooks
so after tour Duty with Soldier of
Fortune Magazine before that before
Soldier four okay before that yeah yeah
they're really young Jim Mars yeah yeah
I don't think he'll ever die
he uh he sends me a message back says
we like this
show us the rest of it I'm thinking oh
[__] no I gotta write the rest of it
oh that problem
so I wrote it uh they they published it
and then I've been writing ever since
and Jim had at least two or three books
from Vietnam as a Green Beret and just
just quality stuff no yeah yeah he get
the banking right anyway so all right so
you get going with the writing and then
you and I were at a shot show gosh what
five six years ago and you were you had
another business you were running at the
time because you've done a few along the
way as you're writing and
um Book Sales were successful you had a
name and people kept asking me hey do
you know John moles yeah yeah we never
served together but yeah I know because
at some point you got involved with
Soldier of Fortune for a little while
magazine two or that just well that was
that's a story in itself Robert K Brown
I had yeah I've known Robert for many
years before uh but uh he uh they sold
the the video rights for Soldier of
Fortune to Hollywood right and they made
two two years of uh of the soldier
Fortune
Series right uh and he'd I got to ask if
I would like from a producer I got to
ask if I would like to send in some
ideas so yeah I'll send it into my idea
so I shipped them to them and they got
they got on air uh there for a couple of
them paid good and I got residuals for
years
uh but then they sold the rights for
video games
to Activision
Activision I wanted to do
a game I Soldier of Fortune so I get a
call on that uh we know your background
we've heard about you would you come up
here and give us some technical advice
on this I said are you going to pay me
and they said yes I said well you got
your answer
[Laughter]
so I go up to go up to uh go up to their
developers and we work for a while and
uh sort of hit it off with the guys and
you gave them some scenarios and told
them some things that were just e
graciously wrong in their way of
understanding got some of it through
some of it not yeah
then I go back home counting my dollars
and
lo and behold about a week later
I get another call and I said we need a
hero for Soldier of Fortune
can we use your name and face
I said same question as before
pay me yes pay me indeed so I became the
I became I got killed by several million
teenage boys and they Soldier of Fortune
game oh there you were really dead in
the game yeah
and you lived to talk about it I live to
talk about it
oh I forgotten about that yes back in
the day yeah wow it's been a long
strange trip indeed so he started
cranking out the books and now we have a
total of 14 written two are still
winning to go through the editing
process itself yeah and you've got 12
out there and uh
amongst them we have
[Music]
um
North Fork Devils Canyon uh boys De Arc
oh this is Monarch Monarch oh is that
what it is are you you French guys and
of course now we got one in Spanish
Rancho Malay suerte malasuerte and now
in English Again Owl Creek so these are
just some of the books that you've been
putting together and
um it's interesting who was one of your
lead characters for your book down Texas
there uh he is the lead character also
in days of fire oh okay who uh run into
some issues with the army so after uh
after the next book uh in that
particular issue which is napalm dreams
uh he uh ran into some issues with the
army so he leaves the Army and becomes a
soldier for her sound familiar does
indeed
Where's Robert K Brown when we need him
so uh so uh
somewhere along the way I thought you
know this is a good character I'm gonna
put him into an impossible situation
so he goes back to the old Family Farm
in Oklahoma
they talk him into becoming a sheriff
now here's the Special Operations guy
who is his methods may not exactly fit
what they teach in Police Academy
first of all make it easy did any of his
messes fit no you please Academy
[Laughter]
scared through seven books now or six
Books five books I'm working on a fixed
one now there you go wow no kidding
What's the name of your lead character
James Carmichael okay it's a nom de
plume that I used many times you always
if you've got to use another name make
sure that you start with the same letter
that your own name is because if you
don't and your name is John and you
George is your cover name hey George and
you look at them like what
that was the fiction route but a lot of
the fiction is is uh entered intertwined
all of the books in here are based on a
crime that actually happened
uh and how he solved them is rather
unique all right well very good we're at
that point where maybe we might be
heading down the end of the trail here
would be uh any final thoughts or
moments in the life of John F Mullins
the first besides being married 60 years
ago to his lovely nurse
that's still like the Primo Act of your
life and the little time of service to
God and Country anything else you wanted
to expound upon before we turn off the
tape recorder I'm working now in the
arms and ammunition industry uh and in
your spare time and not spare time oh
good I'm working on uh working on things
that are Innovative I invented french
bull ammunition God 25 years ago and for
again for some of the young people that
listen to our our tapes and to the uh
podcast
flangeable ammunition is different from
old-fashioned bullets how it defending
rates on impact with any hard surface so
there is no Ricochet no splashback it
enables you to train at ranges that are
almost face to face uh on demonstrations
I shoot it with the gun two inches away
you try to do that on a try to do that
with a regular sure
bullet and you're going to be wiring
pieces of that for longer than I did
wearing all the pieces from the
explosion and again so like if law
enforcement goes into a room and they
open fire if if they miss the target but
hits the wall it dissolves as opposed to
going through the wall and killing that
Millie over there yeah yeah nothing like
losing that Millet on a fire fight yeah
don't want to do that yeah it's it's
mostly for training because to me unless
you live fire train you're not really
training sure uh and you see that all
the time you see people out on a range
uh and they're trying for accuracy and
that's all well and good
but until you go through a door
and know that there's somebody on the
other side that is more than happy to
take you out uh you really don't most
law enforcement don't have that tool and
they don't have it because they don't
have the training facilities
with this as an example I I had my
manufacturing operation set up in an old
B-52 base and on that base was a where
they kept the bombs uh two-story
building stairwells on both sides
concrete block building
made it ideal for
clearing rooms so I put Steel on The
Malt we use steel targets inside but you
could go in there and shoot in any
direction that bullet wasn't coming out
of there because once it hit something
hard it's gone it doesn't exist anymore
and you knew if you're on target or not
yep
so that way you can actually train
realistically Because unless you're
training with live fire it's all an
arcade game yeah because that's even
something that the Jocko willink has
talked about others for making Law
Enforcement Training more realistic yeah
today absolutely particularly now that
law enforcement finds itself being
targeted by the radicals in our country
that are running about the streets a lot
more than we've seen ever in our history
I think oh God it's it's Embark over the
mind it does indeed and then uh any
other careers in between all of these
before we wrap up here go down yeah I uh
I was I was up in Washington doing some
things and
well actually I was in Macedonia I done
a little project there and I saw 911
happening on the monitors in Athens and
I thought oh Jesus Christ I got to get
back to the States yeah so I made it as
far as London and an old ml5 guy a
friend of mine uh just because I can't
go any further he takes me and he feeds
me enough Scotch to keep me from he
keeps from going complete bats yet yeah
yeah so I head on uh back to the States
and uh get get that call and away I go
and I wander around the stands for a
while is that right
did you run into Billy wall when you're
over there oh yeah of course Billy was
working for the ground group for the
agency indeed yeah and so you were
working for another age do we can or
can't it was it was for the for the
agency but it was under a different
color indeed yeah Billy wall is just one
of our SF Legends yeah and uh he's now
92 down there camping out hampley in the
Tampa Bay area oh is he oh yes sir good
I had to live forever he probably will
probably bury all of us
Billy not me I have a goal is that right
what's that goal my goal is to live long
enough to piss off Generations yet
unborn there we go
all right well on that note any final
closing sauce
I think we've covered without everything
that was uh that's a pretty good closing
line I may have to borrow that one just
to live long of the piss off Generations
that haven't been born yet I like that
so anyways as we as we wrap up here
we definitely want to thank uh again
Jocko willink Productions his team with
Deco Charles and uh for making this uh
podcast possible and you see there's no
advertising again thank you to choco and
we thank uh today we thank the military
the First Responders Border Patrol Those
who protect our country and for all the
law enforcement on the street we
continue to pray for your safety and
during these difficult times we hope
that the training will be there to help
improve it and we also want to thank the
men and women who are serving in the
years past their Heroes that like John
Mullins here with us today and of course
we also remember and salute the men and
women who were not able to come home who
have not been able to come home and are
missing an accident today the Vietnam
War alone we still have 1 583
Americans still missing an accident from
the Vietnam War in Southeast Asia and
the way things are gone is we doubt that
many more will be returned or
repatriated
so we thank again Jocko his team for
making this podcast possible and with
that we close God Bless America
amen amen
well welcome back uh John Mullins has
left the building he's on his way back
to Oklahoma and today our technical
technical expert from the 101st Airborne
Chad is with us Loosely indeed but uh
still you're still jumping out of planes
your spirit time but uh John Mullins you
are familiar with our podcast and having
heard this story what's your first
reaction well once again wow as with
most of them all of them I say most like
some are bad no all of them are good and
this just is another good one just
another good one great stories
the whole thing with the with the Ed um
from Arsenal I learned stuff about the
Phoenix project that I never knew yeah I
heard about Prue pru which is their
action arm
and uh just amazing guy it's it's still
around I'll talk about it yeah he's got
great sense of humor too oh yeah he's
got a great sense of humor
it's a it's awesome like I said last
time I was here it's great to see this
talking about history you know the
things that have happened sure in the
past and and getting that
that personalized kind of you know the
putting the face to it right absolutely
all the things you hear and you know and
weeding out the [__] because
sometimes there's some you know
they report the [__] yeah John laid
it down he he cleared up some things on
some stuff I thought he'd clear up a lot
of things particularly with uh there
have been so what Little's been written
is usually bad or just flat wrong yeah
or both it's understandable he doesn't
like journalists do you notice that
we had that first hand yeah two journals
were killed and
um okay let's move right along here it's
good it's good man I love coming out
here and doing this unfortunately your
regular guy could make it and I got to
do it again it's great I get an early
listen to the podcast again our original
Secret Agent Man is busy secret agent
indeed Tom the terrific
so um the what what about it from your
perspective
of having heard some of the other
sidecasts
John's stories are like each guy's story
is so unique yeah and from your side
could you sing or heard some of these
now
they uh what's your final impression on
that
well I I know a few you guys yeah you
guys quote right uh and one thing that I
noticed that on the firing range yeah
the commonality I think amongst all you
guys everybody has a unique story but I
think there's one commonality amongst it
and that is the
the the quality of man the the the
type of person that they are yeah I
don't know the right words to use for
that but uh you listen to them they were
in the moment they were just doing what
they had to do
to complete the mission indeed you know
and that that is that's the one thing
that I kind of get out of most of that I
hear your stories and I hear you know uh
John Placer is when I was here for
John's and and your other guests on your
other podcast it's it's in John's today
it's they're just doing their stuff man
they're just doing their thing and and
they were in the Moment Like It's my job
right now but it's not my life John said
that earlier I don't I can't remember
how he worded it but he was like uh
he wasn't supposed to go out on the
missions right with them yeah he's like
he did that's about 10 years and this is
my job it's not my life is kind of how
he said it I don't remember exactly but
but again go ahead and kick me out yeah
sure yeah go ahead and kick me out this
is then his story is a medic you know
after that after that Ambush the triage
going through that yeah patching people
up and deciding well he's too far gone I
just can't even imagine being a medic
like that the Medics I you got to give
them props I mean because not only
as with most of the guys on a team you
know that you you do you're do rolling
you're dual rolling you're always dual
rolling you got your primary what your
mission is right but you also got your
secondary stuff that you got to do your
your Medics and your camel guys and just
how the well-oiled machine and how it
works together in the end and and the
Medics though man you got to give him
credit because they got to really deal
with some oh yeah an rsf Max has just
continued to amaze me from day one yeah
and I just knew like like told John to
begin it's like I knew I couldn't be a
medic
that was I just wasn't I couldn't do the
Scholastics let alone I don't think I
could have done it either yeah I would
have got kicked out of I wouldn't care I
would have got kicked out of combo and
then got kicked out of medic yeah
yeah
well because that's where John and I
were different in that I knew I couldn't
do medic so I went to combo he went to
Como knew he couldn't do it hated it
became a medic and just like oh it just
became a medic and then goes to language
school for Russian Spanish and French
okay great great men that's that's the
that's the one thing that I noticed well
we're going to continue to keep this uh
to keep this going to thank you for
filling in today sir we appreciate it
and again as we said earlier in our
closing we thank
um Jocko and Echo his team for making
all this possible and uh please feel
free to if you just Google Jocko willink
you have other programs that he does and
for our programs he uh for the audios
that are posted you can go to Spotify or
uh Apple podcast and you type in sogcast
and they'll pop up and now we have
posted so far 17 audio of the interviews
and the first three YouTube Productions
have been posted on YouTube and
um we've had a lot of positive feedback
from that and as we close out again we
always thank our service members today
that protect our country
particularly during these political
times the being in the military is uh
probably uniquely more stressful than
any time in recent years and we pray for
them the safety or our service members
for our First Responders all in the
hospitals on the front lines for we've
seen some odd
challenges that they've come up against
border patrol and law enforcement in
general no matter what the sheriff's
department local police department
anywhere around the world that are there
to keep Law and Order
when we have forces that are trying to
tear apart our country through through
other means that are not respecting Law
and Order so we have a final salute to
them and again to the missing in action
who didn't come home we couldn't come
home hoping someday they will be
repatriated on that thank you sir God
Bless America until next time